[Music]
my name is bug spotty tell from growth
with Sioux Reservation south
[Music]
my name is sent dake Alaska I've been
dancing since I've been about six years
old pretty much all my life do you do
one step on one foot you do on the other
foot and like you try to move like the
grass that's pretty much away how it was
back in the day and gradually it started
changing throughout the years and the
whole style was the old style and
they're kind of more put together and
the contemporaries more out there and a
little more outgoing throughout the song
like a family traditions we watch our
families grow up and do the dance and
that's how we gradually go and start
learning our ways and learning this is a
fun thing that we normally do a way to
bring all our people together and a big
celebration
speed all the people do a lot of singing
do a lot of dancing and it has nothing
to do with you know money or nothing
it's just all of us coming together as
all TL Schwarz all families coming you
know all different Chiefs families
come have a big watching you found
[Music]